I'm in my 20s now and one thing I've
noticed about my 20s is that you really
have to make an effort if you want to
see your friends it's not like high
school where you can just show up and
you're all Hello friends that I take for
granted sing every day because high
school is the most important and
unchanging period of my life this book
and I cannot see past its end when you
were out of school it is a group effort
how about Monday Monday I work all day
well then how about Wednesday Wednesday
works oh no no I have finals but it does
mean that the friends you do see are
your closest and real ones hopefully you
know because if you have to drive two
hours to see them and move around your
entire schedule to meet them
you better believe we enjoy each other's
company tonight we're checking out of a
knife regardless I hope that you try and
maintain the friendships that mean the
most to you because as we get older it
does kind of become this thing that we
actively have to work for but if you're
with the right people it's always worth
it like look at this look at this my
friend made us all these bags okay
friendship doesn't get any better than
your face on a back like this is
seriously my favorite bag now like I
almost cried when I saw it it was just
so thoughtful but anyway um for 2014 I'm
going to be changing my schedule up to
Friday evenings is when I'll be
uploading instead of Monday mornings and
that's pretty much it
stay on Gotham